[Musique]
combien sont ils
ceux qui sont morts
sur l'autoroute est stricte souvient
dans un bassin du port
oui
pour ces
quelques notes jouées en hommage aux
migrants de calais mort en tentant de
rejoindre l'angleterre brise l'attitude
de l'église saint pierre
[Musique]
sur l'autoroute est rare
à
bord
trois personnes y vivent simplement
entouré de messages de soutien les
traits tirés et affaiblis ils sont
toujours là au 20e jour de leur grève de
la faim tant que nos revendications ne
sont pas écoutés elles seront pas
appliquées je m'arrêterai pas en fait je
m'alimente rep attentes
tant que les expulsions en tout cas
auront entendu l'église ne désemplit pas
ya des personnes qui arrivent tout le
temps il ya reçoit des lettres reçois
des messages sur les réseaux sociaux ça
nous porte toutes ces personnes en quête
qui viendront témoigner
ou ailleurs leur soutien leur message en
fait c'est le combat qu'ont décidé de
mener anaïs ludovic et le père philippe
soutenus par plus de 150 associations
ils ont décidé de mettre un coup de
projecteur sur le cauchemar des migrants
et des réfugiés de calais leur campement
serait régulièrement détruits par les
autorités et lorsque par bateau ou
camions ils tentent de traverser la
manche ils risquent à chaque fois leur
vie
alors le déclencheur de cette grève de
la faim c'est le décès d'un jeune
soudanais qui s'appelle nyassa et qui en
tentant de traverser pour aller en
angleterre est tombée d'un camion
est décédée est en fait ceux des ss
c'est vraiment le déclencheur mais
autour de ce décès s'articule aussi une
augmentation de 2 de la violence
policière une augmentation du
harcèlement des associations et ça ça
dure à peu près depuis on va dire
un mois un mois et demi pour l'instant
j'attends plutôt des réponses réelles
voilà une prise de position de la part
du gouvernement soit ils acceptent soi
et refuser les revendications du trio
sont simples la suspension des
expulsions et des démantèlements des
camps de migrants durant toute la trêve
hivernale et la mise en place de points
de distribution de produits de première
nécessité
après un premier contact infructueux le
22 octobre un médiateur a rencontré les
trois grévistes pour initier le dialogue
trouver pour le père philippe leurs
demandes sont non négociables
les policiers se saisissent des tentes
de tout ce qui est là et donc même si le
gouvernement prétexte qu'il est possible
ensuite à la ressourcerie de récupérer
des affaires c'est pratiquement
impossible surtout qu'il ya une
dégradation volontaire de tout de tout
les effets des personnes décédées les
tentes sont déchirés au cutter c'est
quelque chose de très simple lui dire
qu'il ressort de l'humanité la plus
simple donc dans notre esprit il n'y a
pas matière à discussion c'est oui ou
c'est non
d'après le rapport annuel de
l'association humanrights observers près
de notre expulsion sur dix en france
entre novembre 2019 et octobre 2020 ont
lieu à grande synthe et à calais